get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online
for just 12 pounds and we'll give you a
20 pound
amazon gift voucher absolutely free
go to spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash
voucher
hello and welcome to the spectators book
club podcast i'm sam lee the literary
editor of the spectator
this week i'm very pleased to be joined
by lloyd grossman
one of our great renaissance men he's a
television presenter he's a rock
guitarist
he's a pastor source magnate and he's
also as his new book
an elephant in rome bernini the pope and
the making of the eternal city
demonstrates
he's a formidable scholar and
antiquarian and his subject is of course
another renaissance man or a baroque man
at least
this story of bernini lloyd what was it
that made you
think this is the guy to write a book
about where did you first fall in love
with bernini
well i sort of fell in love with one of
bernini's works
before i actually knew it was by bernini
i love italy and one of the strangest
things in rome and romans full of
very strange and intriguing things is
this
um rather large statue of an elephant
the piazza della minerva which i first
stumbled across
you know accidentally on my very first
trip to rome
and subsequently whenever i walked
through that square
which i often did because the very
excellent people tailors
are around the corner and they do rather
beautiful socks
in different sort of ecclesiastical
colors
and on my way to the sock shop i
often sort of pass by the statue of an
elephant
and thought what the heck is a statue of
an elephant doing in the middle of a
roman square
so to satisfy my own curiosity i began
to
try to answer that question and it took
me
straight into the middle of 17th century
rome about which i knew very
little i loved learning and
it was fascinating for me to find out
why that statue was there
and how it fitted in with the whole
general scheme of baroque rome
and the room we love i mean it's it's a
story of the making of the city
uh as much as it is of of one sculptor's
life isn't it because they're so
entwined
yeah and i think you know it wasn't
intended
as such because of course things have
changed hugely
since i started writing it what's
particularly interesting
now sam i think is the fact that you
know for the first time in history
half the population of the world are
living in cities and
because of the pandemic
we are now beginning to question the
whole
rationale for the existence of cities
we're beginning to look at the whole
future of cities
you know people are talking about more
working from home
you know the flight to the countryside
etc etc yet
cities are what have created
and supported our civilization cities
are what make
museums possible and opera houses and
theaters
and restaurants etc etc so to look at a
city and history like 17th century rome
and kind of question you know what makes
it beautiful
inspiring enriching is quite an
important topic
for the moment yeah and and you do set
it in a kind of historical context i
mean
you know bernini you know he had a long
career
and he went through half a dozen popes
and you know at least
significant relations with four of them
but
you know you begin the arc a bit earlier
because rome was sort of
decrepid before you know lots of it was
quite decrepit and in need of
in need of change wasn't it before
bernini came along i mean yeah
rome rome had got pretty shabby
and you know the population at shrunk
the city had really sort of turned in on
itself
and there were some great
popes who tried to revive rome you know
i suppose most notably the
fabulously comically named sixtus the
fifth
who was the first pope to begin
planting obelisks in prominent spaces
in order to provide clear guidance for
pilgrims and tourists but it was
really alexander the seventh
uh with his his forensic skills his
skills as a diplomat
his vision who thought that the
the best way to combat what was very
much
the waning political power of the papacy
the best way to combat that was really
through the invention of what we now
call self-diplomacy
namely look roman's no longer a great
political
power it hasn't been for years a
military power it's not a diplomatic
power
but i will make it the most significant
cultural power and that will hugely
enhance
the declining prestige of the church
and it was an amazingly innovative thing
to do
and in order to do that he found the
greatest artist
of his time bernini gave him a blank
checkbook and they became the greatest
artistic double act in history each
equally important
yeah i mean your subtitle is bernini the
pope and the making of the eternal city
i mean you're
it's clear that this relation of
patronage was kind of hugely important
to
bernie being able to do what he did yeah
because look
there wasn't a commercial market for art
the commercial market fraud
really didn't exist in a normal way
until the 18th century
and if you were a great artist
and you wanted to do big things you had
to find a great patron
and the greatest patron of all was the
pope
you know bernini was kind of a mozart
like genius i mean as a child he was
creating very
enthralling and impressive works of art
and he came to the attention of the
papacy at a very early age
successive popes employed him to do some
wonderful stuff
but it was really the greatness
of the vision of alexander vii that
enabled bernini to
totally fly and to create the amazing
works that we still benefit from today i
mean you've got photographs in the book
of sculptures that bernini made when he
was
sort of 12 he was so adept
and even at the age of 12 13
14 not only was he technically
very clever but he had this amazing
psychological insight you know they are
real portraits they're not just icons
they're not
symbols they're not cliches they're
actually portraits that give you a real
insight
into the psychology of the person he's
portrayed and that's amazing for a kid
you know a teenager to do that is just
fabulous actually
yeah and he knew it i mean you said at
one point earlier
bernini didn't talk himself down in fact
he might have been
a bit of a bit of a boar in conversation
yeah i think that
you know in truth modesty
is not often a characteristic of great
artists
and particularly in the rough and tumble
you know very
violent and vicious and
go-getting world of the 17th century
you didn't hide your light under a
bushel you know either you promoted
yourself or you fell
by the wayside and benini
was a great self-promoter i didn't think
he even knew what self-doubt was
he was the greatest rather like like
mohammed army
i am the greatest and you keep saying
you're the greatest and
if you happen also to be the greatest
it's a winning combination
there's a lovely sense you you give
early on of him setting out his stall
you know one of his early big
sculptures is his david yeah as you read
it it's a direct repost to
michelangelo's david
yeah you know and actually i mean look
like everyone else
i've been kind of brought up to believe
that you know
michelangelo's david is like the
greatest thing ever
when you compare it to bernini's david i
think it really
really pales because where's
michelangelo's david
is to me rather static and you know it's
a calvin klein underwear ad
based without the underwear and without
the underwear
and bernini's david is full of tension
and energy and ambition
and ruthlessness and determination
it's so exciting bernie means david and
it's also a self-portrait it is bernini
determined to take on to slay the
goliaths
of culture and to become top dog which
he did
so in this century you know he's living
at the same time as
rembrandt and velazquez and vermeer et
cetera et cetera
he gets to the position where he is
regarded as the greatest
artist in europe and that's pretty
extraordinary
tell me a bit about his origins because
it's it's a sort of
you know family i mean you know he
didn't come from that much
you know it's a family sculpting story
as well i mean his father was a sculptor
as you described yeah his father was
a very good jobing sculptor his father
had emerged from
the more affluent end of tuscan
peasantry
was a very very very deft
sculpture lacking in imagination
not very good at composition but
extremely good at execution
and at a time you know this is the
counter reformation
there's a lot of church building or a
lot of
church enrichment going on pietro
bernini the father
goes to work in naples naples at that
time i mean we
it's hard to think about it now but you
know at that time i think
naples was the most populated city in
europe
and certainly one of the richest so
pietro bernini goes there to work
and is very very busy and he's good
enough to be brought to the notice of
people
in rome which of course is where
everything is happening
and he comes to rome to do a lot of work
on the basilica of santa maria machiare
bernini so at the age of five or six
little gian lorenzo
comes to rome and you know he grows up
at the knee at the ankle whatever you
want to call it
are a very busy sculptor who's working
on one of the great roman churches so
sculpture the dust of marble
the sound of chisels is in little
bernini's blood from the time
he can remember yeah bernina doesn't
always appear as a hugely attractive
character in this book but
he does have reserves of filial loyalty
doesn't he it's quite late in his career
there's a lovely detail of his
sticking up for one of his old dad's
sculptures yeah yeah he's very good at
protecting the family reputation
he's very bad at ever giving anyone
other than god any credit so
he loves to talk about you know how god
gave him his talents etc etc
he never really says he never never says
thanks dad yeah but when is it which is
it
the pope who comes after alexander the
seventh is it clement who
yes wants to knock down a kind of
indifferent sculpture that his dad's
made
yeah and bernini leaps to the defense of
it but i think
that's long after his father has died
and
to me it's kind of more about protecting
the bernini
brand than about filial deviation
right you said you know he grew up with
hammer and chisel sort of ringing in his
ears
he seems to be a complete kind of
workaholic or monomaniac
there's some quote you come up with that
he says he sort of spent about two hours
of his life or
two months of his life not actually
sculpting he yes
yeah he loved being in the studio
you know he probably wasn't like the
best
father and husband he was a workaholic
he was undeniably a genius
possessed with demonic energy and an
endless
endless supply of things he wanted to
execute
and of course being the most famous
artist in europe there was
a constant stream of commissions coming
his way
and those commissions ranged from you
know magnificent
huge urban projects like the piazza of
saint peter's in vatican city
down to designing a sort of looking
glass
for queen christina of sweden so
you know he turned out a huge range of
things
and he wanted to enrich his family he
became
very very rich by the time he died he
had a magnificent house
he left a lot of money he had a big
family to support
and you know he wanted to make it he
wanted to make it and making it
was probably more important to him than
having a
cozy fireside chats with the no doubt
long suffering
mrs bernini before mrs bernini though
there was this one kind of extraordinary
episode in his love life
costanza who he fell in love when he was
in his mid-30s he fell in love with this
very voluptuous woman called costanza
and this was great they had this
passionate love affair there were two
problems number one she was married
to his favorite assistant
and number two she was also
um having a bit of a ding-dong with
bernini's brother
so this caused
a huge scandal i mean bernini found out
that his brother
was you know one of the people with whom
he was being three-timed or two times
brenneny chased his brother through rome
tried to kill him and failed
he you know rather unpleasantly bernini
hired a thug
to ambush costanza and slash her across
the face with a razor
she was sent to a home for fallen women
bernini was merely ordered to get
married to a respectable girl
and he did it was pretty sordid actually
but what it did produce was this
magnificent portrait bust of costanza
which is now in the bargello museum in
florence
and it's a remarkable work of art
firstly because
it's very intimate it's it's very highly
sexually charged
but it's probably the first time in the
history of western sculpture
that a portrait bust was made
of an ordinary woman because previously
you know marble busts are a very big
deal previously the only subjects for
marvel busts would be
gods and goddesses and members of royal
or aristocratic families
and suddenly here with bernini's bust of
costanza you have a
real normal woman of the 17th century
immortalized in a marvel past and it's a
remarkable thing to see
you talk there about him doing something
new in what other ways was
bernini's genius something that changed
things something that brought in
innovation artistically i mean we talk
about the baroque
and benini as the pinnacle of that what
does that mean and what was what was new
and important about it
well the baroque is a really sort of
astonishing moment in the history of art
it's much easier to recognize
than to define and
as someone said i think it's quite a
good definition
when there's a curve where you expect
there to be a straight line
that's baroque barack it's very
expressive
it's very emotional it's kind of
irrational
it's very exciting it's
slightly to use an anachronism slightly
kind of psychedelic in a way
it's an extreme but extremely moving
form of art and what benini did which
you know because there are a lot of
other practitioners of barack and indeed
some of the german baroque is more
extreme than
roman brock i think but what bernini did
was
he very much he often combined
architectural sculpture
painting and lighting and in an
almost kind of cinematic way he used all
the arts
to create an emotional effect and this
was something very very new
very new which still moves us today
still affects us today so for example
when you look at the great the bold
aquino
which is the bronze shelter over the
high altar and subpoeters
30 meters of broad and sometimes pretty
extraordinary just in scale
when you look at it you sort of think
well what is it
is it a building is it a work of
sculpture is it decoration
what is it and bernini brought all the
arts together
to create an incredible emotional effect
on the spectator yeah now you talk in
the in the book as well about how
the baroque strikes a kind of political
moment as well that it's
the particular expression of how the
church
wanted to project itself through rome
and through the roman built environment
but you know why is that what made it
distinctive because it's it's that's the
realm that substantially survives to
today isn't it
yeah i mean the church convenes the
council of trent
as a response to the reformation this is
in the
you know early to mid 16th century
and one of the things the council of
trent just goes on for
decades i think decades and
one of the things that emerges from the
council of trent
is the idea that imagery should be
used actively by the church
to encourage intensity of faith
encourage allegiance to the church so
this commitment this ideological and
policy commitment
to the use of imagery gives birth
to the baroque gives birth to the idea
that
as someone said the temples of faith
should be more attractive than the
temples of sin
and kind of really proves that
the downside of it because you know very
explicitly the barack
is you know kind of a propaganda
instrument the downside of it is the
fact that the baroque
was always looked at with some suspicion
in england because uh the british the
english
looked at barack and they thought no no
no it's not for us
it's too much about the catholic church
it's too much about
absolute rule it's probably too
emotional we don't go for that sort of
thing
so when you look at the english baroque
as practiced by people like hawks moore
and van buren christopher wren
it's rather well mannered english
baroque is terribly polite
i mean it's awfully nice you can
actually bring english brock
home you could date english
you would not introduce italian baroque
to your parents
so the british have always had a little
bit of a problem with full-blown
barack as marvelous as blenheim and
castle howard and saint paul's cathedral
law
they are restrained baroque not
crazy brock like you get in italy and
germany
yeah it's a lovely digital you're said
to have got a sort of baroque
aspect to the piazza outside saint
peter's
you say this kind of curved colonnade is
intended to be
almost sort of a pair of arms yeah i
mean bernini was
very explicit he said that you know when
he was designing the colonnade
it is meant to represent the embracing
arms of the church
it's meant to inspire the faithful it's
meant to
encourage those who have left the church
to come back
and although nowadays we wouldn't
necessarily think of those colonies
explicitly as embracing arms there is no
question that
anyone anyone whether they go to church
and don't go to church or atheist or
faithful or whatever
anyone standing in that square
will feel this incredible sense of
uplift and inspiration and spirituality
it's one of the most
remarkable urban spaces in the world
and it shows the power of architecture
to make life dramatic and to
enhance life and you know we're often in
danger of
losing the idea that architecture can
really do
wonderful positive things for people now
there is a bit of a tug of love that
goes on in the course but which is
interesting seems to me because it
follows the sort of political shift in
power
louis xiv takes a fantasy to bernini and
the pope can't really say no
kenny when bernini has to go to france
at one point yeah bernini has to go to
france because
bernini is so famous that
he becomes the sort of trophy in the
european power struggle
one of the most interesting things in
the 17th century is the fact that we see
the
decline of spain as the greatest power
in europe
and the rise of france and the rise of
france is being led very much by louis
xiv
who knows what he wants and he looks
around
and he thinks no no look i am the
greatest monarch in europe
i want the greatest artist to come and
work for me and of course the pope says
well no
actually i mean bernini's quite busy
they don't really want him to leave room
and louis xiv says no well actually
you know we really need him here in
paris
and you know there's a lot of diplomatic
tuning and throwing and eventually the
pope is forced
to let nini go to paris
where allegedly louis xiv wants him to
design
a new extension to the louvre and it's
all a total disaster
because bernini you know he doesn't
really like
leaving italy he doesn't like the french
he thinks the french are all the second
rate have no
taste and no talent and so on so the
whole thing
is a total disaster his designs for the
louvre
which are actually beautiful are never
executed because they're regarded as
wildly impractical
and um he goes back to italy
having sort of made his appearance in
france but having failed to make a
permanent mark in france
other than to be regarded as a sort of
egotistical
rather boorish italian primadonna
do you think he regarded that as a
failure
you know something i don't think he ever
regarded
anything as a failure i think he would
have
you know this of course is you know
crazy speculation
he would have thought that the failure
was louis the 14th
he would have thought you know isn't it
funny how louis xiv failed to appreciate
what a genius i am that's a
impregnable self-regard yeah well let's
let's i mean you know you're talking
about
the impractical and you know let's come
back to the center of this book or the
kind of
original inspiration this crazy elephant
it had an obelisk on top of it was a
detail i don't think we've mentioned
still has an obelisk on top of it as
detailed i think we mentioned it
why an obelisk and why an elephant
because both of those things had great
considerable meaning yeah well the
romans
kind of fell in love with obelisks
really just around the time of you know
around that classic time of caesar and
cleopatra
and egypt was hugely important to rome
firstly because of its geopolitical role
in control egypt you
kind of helped to control eastern
mediterranean and secondly
egypt was where the grain was produced
which was feeding the growing roman
population so egypt was the bread basket
for him
and when octavian who of course later
became
emperor augustus conquered egypt
he wanted to bring back some souvenirs
and you know
hey what's the best souvenir to bring
back well i can't move the pyramids
but i can just about figure out how to
move the obelisks
so obelisks began appearing in rome as
souvenirs and more trophies during the
reign of augustus
and led to the situation where rome
which now has 13 obelisks has more
standing obelisks
than egypt itself and more than any city
in the world
rather amusingly obelisks
eventually became a great sort of
metropolitan status symbol and i saw a
clipping from a new york newspaper
in the late 19th century which was
saying that
new york must have an obelisk because
rome has gone over this paris has got an
obelisk
london has got an obelisk we can't be a
great city unless we have our own
obelisk
but rome is very much a city of obelisks
for
excellence because they're a symbol of
the importance of egypt jerome and also
a symbol of roman preeminence you know
hey egypt was the greatest civilization
in world history by the way until we
came along
and the fact that we could take what we
wanted as souvenirs
really shows how important we are as
roma and they sort of like to
christianize them though didn't they i
mean they sort of stick a
said peter on top or a christian
inscription around the bottom
yeah what they used to do because they
were pagan monuments what they used to
do is they used to
exercise them and then put a cross on
top
so they christianized them and made them
part of the symbolism
of holy rome you know
rome the holy city all these pagan
egyptian obelisks
though it's true isn't it that at least
i mean obviously not during the
years of sort of papal states but in
classical rome
they would sort of adopt some of the
egyptian gods as well there was a kind
of syncretism that went on
oh totally yeah the egyptian gods
became hugely important in rome isis was
hugely important for example
and you know the persistence of egyptian
motifs
is quite significant because we even
finally
medieval things in rome that use
egyptian motifs
and there was also a fascination with
egyptian philosophy egyptian mysticism
some of which was meant to pre-figure
christianity
so egypt had this kind of weird grip
on both classical rome and christian
rome
there's a lovely kind of side side issue
or
subplot in a book of them desperately
trying to decipher hieroglyphics which
of course until
the rosetta stone wasn't possible but
you've got for instance consulting on
the crazy elephant with the obelisk on
top is athanasius kircher he says an
amazing character this sort of
the last man who knew everything kind of
figure yes he was extraordinary because
he was this german jesuit who
sort of claimed to be the person who
knew
everything and all of his contemporaries
believed
that he was the last man who knew
everything
yet at the same time people began to
suspect that he actually didn't know
very much at all he was very good at
winging
it and it was one of these things he got
himself in
so deep by claiming to kind of master
every sort of subject
that um when he didn't know the answer
to something he just can't make it up
and he had all sorts of absolutely
baloney
theories about everything from geology
to hieroglyphics
and people kind of believed it because
you know he had a good act he was he was
very fluent he was enormously productive
he used to produce these huge books
about every subject you can imagine and
um
he was one of the house intellectuals
of the papacy in many ways an admirable
figure because he actually
did aspire to know everything but on the
other hand
possibly a bit of a snake oil salesman
bit of a fraud
well the elephant then underneath that
obelisk
they have been important in in italian
history since hannibal
but there weren't many elephants around
at that point were there no there
weren't
um occasionally elephants would come on
tour
of europe that was quite important in
the 16th century there was quite a
famous elephant who was given to the
pope as a presence by the king of
portugal
and he became a great celebrity and
um the important sight to see in rome
but elephants were also regarded they
were
thought to be and this you know dates
way back
to you know sort of greek literature
elephants were thought to be very
spiritual animals they were
thought to be rather religious they were
thought to be
models of chastity you know and
uh one of the ancient writers
said oh what's so marvelous about
elephants is they you know elephants
only have sex if they want to conceive
you know so elephants didn't go in for a
lot of slap and typical
just for the heck of it i think you
could find the same theory expounded in
foucault's history of sexuality it goes
right forwards
so you know elephants were accredited
with all sorts of you know
rather marvelous uh symbolic value which
is why
it wasn't regarded as particularly weird
that uh bernini decided to um
memorialize his friend alexander's
statue of an elephant when you say you
memorialized him you you've played the
suggestion that actually the
there's a bit of a caricature of the
pope in the elephant
well yeah that's possible because
bernini bernini essentially
invented the art of caricature and
his caricatures of significant roman
people really almost looked like those
sort of hirschfeld caricatures
which were you know from the 1950s and
60s
in new york they're very very modern
looking
so caricature was something that bernini
enjoyed
and if you look at the elephant of the
piazza della minerva very closely
it's not anatomically the most correct
elephant you've ever seen there's
something sort of
spookily anthropomorphic spookily human
about it
and it has been speculated and i don't
think sort of
crazily it has been speculated that
the elephant itself is actually a
caricature of alexander the seventh
and i think you know there's something
in that it adds a bit of
piculty to the whole thing it does but
another detail that had some people see
is that you know you've written a book
about benini and the pope and the making
of of the
eternal city focusing on this elephant
but bernini didn't carve the elephant
you reveal at the end no you know these
big artists workshops
i mean all the great artists had
very large workshops so for example i
mean you looked at a lot of old master
paintings you know
quite often there'd be one specialist
who'd come and paint the dogs in the
picture there'd be another one who'd
work on the drapery
on the fabric etc etc so
the delegation of work was not
um particularly unusual in the 17th
century
at one stage i mean bernini employed
almost
every well-known sculptor in rome
because he had so many commissions his
genius
was in the design the conception
the overall approach to things and then
you know like everyone else he delegated
the work to his favorite followers
the elephant as far as we know and this
is only as far as we know
was mostly carved by a very talented
follower of bernini called urcalef
ferrata
but he would have done it under the very
supervision of bernini and bernini
probably would have contributed some of
the finishing touches etc etc etc
so it's not unusual for works of art in
those days to be very very heavily
delegated because
bernini was running a big business
now i mean you said earlier which i
thought was
a nice way of expressing it that you
know you couldn't take italian baroque
home to meet your parents and this is no
exception
i mean you said that there's a strong
suggestion that the elephants about to
take a [ __ ] in the general direction of
the dominican friary
do you credit that i mean what how do
people's come to that conclusion
i think so i mean i saw one of the um
there's a much earlier very large
bernini um model of the elephant
as he originally conceived it and one of
the differences between the original
conception of the elephants and the way
in which the elephant was finally
executed is that the elephant
of the piazza development minerva is
kind of moving his tail
off to the side and it does seem
as if he might be just about to have a
rather large
dump in the direction of the dominican
monastery
which would make sense because number
one
bernini had a very dirty sense of humor
he had a very scatological sense of
humor and in fact dirty humor
practical jokes were very very commonly
amongst the upper echelons of
17th century roman society and bernini
who was very close to the jesuits didn't
really like the dominicans very much the
dominicans had tried
to interfere hugely with the creation of
the elephant
because it had been found in the grounds
of their monastery
so the idea that bernini
had the elephant putting as it were two
fingers up to the dominicans
i think um really has a lot of
credibility
well that's a lovely thought to end on
lloyd
thank you very much indeed for your time
thank you very much for listening we
hope you enjoyed this podcast and if you
did we very much hope that you'll
subscribe
on your podcast provider of choice and
or rate and review us
well especially if you liked it if you
hated it don't forget you have to review
it
and equally if there's something that
you wanted to ask us about something you
think we could do better or something
you enjoyed please do send us your
feedback to podcast
spectator dot co dot uk thanks again for
listening and please join us for our
next episode
get 12 weeks of the spectator in print
and online for just 12 pounds
and we'll give you a 20 pound amazon
gift voucher
absolutely free go to spectator dot co
dot uk
forward slash voucher